Okay guys, we're gonna do this next podcast from our pool. So, do you have your towels and your sunblock? And I got the floaties. I got the sun. You're supposed to be wearing no trunks? Yeah, no, I don't want any tan lines. I don't want anything. Okay, man, well this is not.
好的伙计们，我们接下来的播客要在泳池里录了。你们带毛巾和防晒霜了吗？我带了浮板，还有阳光。你是不是没穿泳裤？对，我不想晒出痕迹，我什么都不想要。好吧，伙计，这可不行。
Well, why are you wearing a two piece? Because I want to cover my meats and cheeses. That's why. Ooh, this is gonna make a big splash. This is wonderful, Sean. Thank you. Come smartless everyone. Smart.
那你为什么穿两件套？因为我想遮住我的肉和奶酪。就是这样。噢，这会溅起很大的水花。这太棒了，肖恩。谢谢。欢迎来到Smartless。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Hey gang.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。嘿，伙计们。
Hey gang guys. Will, why do you have green screen behind you? Are we doing an animation episode today? Yeah, we're gonna do a full, because I just wanted people to feel free to do whatever they want behind me. Oh, that's been happening for years. So we can put in like, we are, why is that there?
嘿，伙计们。威尔，你身后为什么有绿幕？我们今天是在做动画片吗？对，我们要拍个完整的，因为我只是想让大家在我身后随意发挥。噢，这都好几年了。所以我们可以放，比如，我们是，为什么那儿会有那个？
I gotta do a junket this afternoon. Will you put like a background behind you, like a image? Yeah. What would that image be? Uh, it's of an ice cream truck. Oh, so it's a drama. I have the same one. It's a, it's a like a four quarter prestige film.
我今天下午有个媒体见面会。你会把你身后放个背景吗，比如一张图片？会。那会是什么图片？呃，是一辆冰淇淋车。噢，所以这是部剧情片。我也有一样的。这是一部，这是一部四分之一的声望电影。
It's the Shawnee story. And that's what you have the jacket about. The history of ice cream. There's a liquid joke in there somewhere? No. But no, no, it's for twisted metal. So there's the big guys, you know, sweet tooth is my character.
这是肖尼的故事。这就是你穿夹克的原因。冰淇淋的历史。这里面有个关于液体的笑话吗？没有。不，不，这是为了《烈火战车》。所以有那些大块头，你知道，我的角色是“甜牙”。
Oh, yeah. That's your new nickname. Sweet tooth. Now, do they send you the green? Or do they ask you to go to a hobby shop and get a nice, nice big... They sent me the green in this light that use this big bright light that you see. Don't make like you don't know what a ring light is.
噢，对。那是你的新绰号。甜牙。他们是把绿幕寄给你了吗？还是让你去工艺品店买个大大的……他们把绿幕和这个你看到的明亮大灯一起寄给我了。别装作你不知道什么是环形灯。
And they could saw, they're all over your house. Never had one. That's not true. I had one before, but I haven't used one since pandemic. Speaking of pandemic, Sean, what are you eating? Cheez-its. Cheez-its. But they're white cheddar cheez-its.
他们到处都是，你家里肯定也有。我从来没用过。那不是真的。我以前有一个，但疫情之后就没用过了。说到疫情，肖恩，你在吃什么？芝士脆。芝士脆。但那是白切达芝士味的。
They're just my rod. Oh, they looked white. Have you had the white cheddar cheez-its? Is there something else? No, are they good? cheddar cheese? It's is there such thing? I just don't know asking for you know me asking for a friend if you have them please send them I do want to just do another shout out to her friends at checks mix slash bugles. What did you guys get like a big box? Oh my god. I had the Cool Ranch. Was it Cool Ranch Beagles? They were.
它们只是我的……噢，它们看起来是白色的。你吃过白切达芝士脆吗？还有别的吗？不，它们好吃吗？切达芝士？有这种东西吗？我只是不知道，替朋友问的，如果你有的话请寄给我。我确实想再向Chex Mix和Bugles的朋友们致谢。你们拿到了什么，一大盒吗？噢天哪。我拿到了Cool Ranch口味的。是Cool Ranch Bugles吗？是的。
They sent everything. They sent everything. Funnians and anything. You know what, I'm going to stop talking. Because my instinct right there was like, oh, I never eat that stuff because I had hold water in my face for five years. I'm not going to do it anymore because people now are coming up to me after the doc is I'm going to say, hey, man, so sorry to hear about your food disorder.
他们什么都寄了。他们寄了所有东西。Funyuns还有别的。你知道吗，我不说了。因为我刚才的本能反应是，噢，我从不吃那些东西，因为我过去五年脸部一直浮肿。我以后再也不这样了，因为纪录片播出后，人们现在走过来对我说，嘿，伙计，很遗憾听到你的饮食失调。
You're your food issues. That's not true. That's not true. Yeah. He's like, hey, man, so sorry to hear about your food disorder, your food issues. That's not true. That's not true. Yeah, and I said, well, you know, a lot of it's true, but comedy kind of lives in the exaggeration. And so I'm leaning into it and, you know, kind of playing my role in the whole world. Yeah, just for the record, we've all seen you eat candy and other stuff.
你的饮食问题。那不是真的。那不是真的。是的。他说，嘿，伙计，很遗憾听到你的饮食失调，你的饮食问题。那不是真的。那不是真的。是的，我说，嗯，你知道，很多是真的，但喜剧往往存在于夸张之中。所以我顺着它说，你知道，在整个世界里扮演好我的角色。是的，郑重声明，我们都见过你吃糖果和其他东西。
Yeah, oh my God. Oh my God. Oh my God. And shit pig most of the time. He does. He does. But when I want it, I have it. We should. It should be noted because I'm off. I'm often at the at the sharp edge of that that point that is puncturing you.
是的，噢天哪。噢天哪。噢天哪。而且大部分时间像头猪一样。他确实是。他确实是。但当我想吃的时候，我就会吃。应该指出的是，因为我经常处于那个刺痛你的尖端。
That I have seen you devour more shit than anybody. I know. So, but I love giving you Sean. I love giving you because what happens is as you say that there's a larger person inside of you waiting to get out and so you're trying not to feed the beast as much as you can. As hard as you can. If you want to step me, you'd find three after school specials of teenagers that wake up in front of. I brought it up before. Do you remember when we were up at Pebble and you had an off week, you got to sort of,
我见过你吞下的垃圾比任何人都多。我知道。所以我喜欢逗你，肖恩。我喜欢逗你，因为正如你所说，你内心有一个更大的人在等待出来，所以你尽量不去喂养那头野兽。尽你所能。如果你想阻止我，你会发现三个青少年在放学后醒来的特别节目。我之前提过。你还记得我们在圆石滩，你有一个休息周，你可以……
and we would sit down and go, can we, this is my favorite, they go, so as we sat down, not even the way or somebody to go, hey, can we start your off some ice water? You go, yeah, and if you got a basket of bread back there, you'd be like, hey, man. That's right. I remember that restaurant. It was like immediately. Yeah, and I looked at you like, who are you?
我们会坐下来，我说，我们可以，这是我最喜欢的，他们说，当我们坐下时，甚至还没点餐，有人走过来说，嘿，我们要先给你们上点冰水吗？你说，好的，如果你们后面有面包篮，你会说，嘿，伙计。没错。我记得那家餐厅。就像立刻一样。是的，我看着你，心想，你是谁？
They were still handing out the menus. Yeah. Yeah. You're at LA. I was way. LA. I was at, I went to a restaurant. We don't have bread in the house.
他们还在发菜单呢。是的。是的。你在洛杉矶。我当时在。洛杉矶。我当时在，我去了一家餐厅。我们家里没有面包。
You know, I got super, super, super, super stone with rain on my friend Raina. This is years and years ago, we were in New York. I was high as a kite and I was starving. We walked down the street, we walked into a restaurant and the matriety goes, how many? And I go, sees her salad. Not even joking.
你知道，我和我的朋友雷娜喝得超级超级超级超级醉。那是很多年前的事了，我们在纽约。我高得像只风筝，饿坏了。我们走在街上，走进一家餐厅，领位员问，几位？我说，凯撒沙拉。没开玩笑。
I swear to God, I wasn't even joking. I swear to God, I wasn't even joking. And Raina grabs me, I'm like, what, I go, I just wanted to start off like so before we went sit down, if the scissors they're waiting. I do like a Caesar salad mix at the table. I think there's something very, very refined about that. You know, Caesar salad mix at the table. I think there's something very, very refined about that. You know, she's a salad mix at the table, get your salad chopped in the kitchen so they bring it to your top. That's also a good way. I do like my dressing on the side. That doesn't give me food issues. Does it? I just think that people over dress salads. Yeah, I do. I want, you know, it's too soggy. And it should be noted that in a town, and by town in the NLA, in a town where a lot
我发誓，我真的没开玩笑。我发誓，我真的没开玩笑。雷娜抓住我，我说，怎么了，我说，我只是想先开始，在我们坐下之前，如果剪刀在那儿等着。我喜欢在桌边做凯撒沙拉。我觉得那非常非常精致。你知道，在桌边做凯撒沙拉。我觉得那非常非常精致。你知道，在桌边做凯撒沙拉，在厨房把沙拉切好，然后送到你桌上。那也是个好方法。我确实喜欢把酱汁放在旁边。那不会给我带来饮食问题，对吧？我只是觉得人们给沙拉加太多酱了。是的，我同意。我想要，你知道，太湿了。而且应该指出的是，在这个镇上，我指洛杉矶，在这个镇上，很多人……
of people, when they get burgers or they get stuff, they're like, no, Brad, can I get that wrapped in lettuce or whatever? Every time on the off weeks, on Sunday nights, when we do burgers, Jason always gets full bun. And he has a bunch of burgers. I know. No, I do the single. I do the single.
当他们点汉堡或其他东西时，他们会说，不要面包，能用生菜包着吗？每次在休息周，周日晚上，当我们吃汉堡时，杰森总是点全套面包。他吃了一堆汉堡。我知道。不，我吃单层的。我吃单层的。
Watch it. I do. I do burger. I've seen you do two burgers. Oh, two burgers, no, but not double patty. No, I do double patty. I do two burgers. Well, you have, I do one patty per burger because that's the proper ratio with the bread, right? That's right.
看着点。我吃。我吃汉堡。我见过你吃两个汉堡。噢，两个汉堡，不，但不是双层肉饼。不，我吃双层肉饼。我吃两个汉堡。嗯，你有，我每个汉堡只放一块肉饼，因为那是面包的正确比例，对吧？没错。
And that is me. A fool would have double meat. It's too much meat. Tell that to the big Mac. Well, he's got another piece of bread in there to eat it out. He does have a piece of bread in there. Yeah. It is.
那就是我。傻瓜才会放双层肉。肉太多了。去告诉巨无霸吧。嗯，他里面还有另一片面包来平衡。他里面确实有一片面包。是的。确实。
Yeah. Yeah. That's a cool, big Mac. Okay. He's the bread. He knows Yeah, some cool. It's your neck. Okay. It's the brain. He knows what he's doing. All right.
是的。是的。那是个很酷的巨无霸。好吧。他是面包。他知道，是的，很酷。这是你的脖子。好吧。这是大脑。他知道他在做什么。好吧。
All right. So, where do you guys get a load of this guest? Wait, wait, wait, wait. Right. I just wanted to show you guys. Yeah, Sean, I saw you were playing with... Look at the... Wait, but look.
好吧。那么，你们从哪儿弄到这个嘉宾的？等等，等等，等等，等等。对。我只是想给你们看看。是的，肖恩，我看到你在玩……看这个……等等，看。
It's all our faces are on this room. It's the Rubik's Cube. It's the Rubik's Cube with our faces. And then... No. The world's smartest game for the world's dumbest podcast. I know. We don't we don't know how this all happened, but we're not going to question it too much. Here's the deal. Yeah. Right. The smartest toy of all time just got smartlessless guys. So in celebration of the smartless podcast, third year anniversary,
我们所有人的脸都在这个上面。这是魔方。这是印着我们脸的魔方。然后……不。世界上最聪明的游戏，给世界上最愚蠢的播客。我知道。我们不知道这一切是怎么发生的，但我们不会深究。事情是这样的。是的。对。有史以来最聪明的玩具刚刚变得Smartless了，伙计们。所以为了庆祝Smartless播客三周年，
we have partnered with Rubik's Cube to make a limited edition, limited quantity, smartless Rubik's Cube. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I've always wanted to be one of those people that can solve it like three seconds. You ever see those guys? Wait, can you do that? Yeah. Oh, yeah. No, but there No, but there's a way to do it. I can't, I don't know. No, they, Jay, they mix it up and then they solve it in three seconds. The kid just said a new record last week or something.
我们与魔方合作制作了一款限量版、限量发行的Smartless魔方。是的。是的。是的。是的。我一直想成为那种能在三秒钟内解开它的人。你见过那些人吗？等等，你能做到吗？是的。噢，是的。不，但没有……不，但有办法做到。我不能，我不知道。不，他们，杰，他们把它打乱，然后在三秒钟内解开。那个孩子上周刚创下新纪录什么的。
He looks at it and goes, yeah, and he goes, and puts it down. Yeah, I saw that. I saw that. It's fucking, it's amazing. And by the way, it's a little bit of a cheat though because you can see our faces. You just line our faces up.
他看了一眼，说，是的，然后他走过去，把它放下。是的，我看到了。我看到了。这太他妈神奇了。顺便说一句，这有点作弊，因为你可以看到我们的脸。你只需要把我们的脸对齐就行了。
Or yeah, it still takes some skills. We're not smart enough to do it. But listen, if you're smart enough to do it, we want you to try to get smart enough to do it. Yeah. Go ahead over there to that merch store, you know, that smart list shop. And buy one. Well, don't you can't do it. Buy it.
或者是的，这仍然需要一些技巧。我们不够聪明，做不到。但听着，如果你足够聪明能做到，我们希望你尝试变得足够聪明去做到。是的。去那个周边商店，你知道，那个Smartless商店。买一个。好吧，别，你做不到。买它。
Do we need to tell that what it was? It's a www.shopsmartlist.com. Anyway, Jay, so are we interrupted? You're interrupted. Yes, I apologize. I apologize to our guest. Hey, guys, I don't know if you, I don't know if you like, if you guys, wait, hang on, I'm saying it. It's so wrong.
我们需要告诉他们那是什么吗？是www.shopsmartless.com。总之，杰，我们被打断了吗？你被打断了。是的，我道歉。我向我们的嘉宾道歉。嘿，伙计们，我不知道你们，我不知道你们是否，等等，等等，我在说。这太错了。
I'm going to start with a round of applause. I don't know. Hey, hey, guys, I don't know. Tight not mystery guests. Here we come. I don't know if Hey, guys, I don't know tight not mystery guest. Here we come. I don't know if you guys like folks. Hey guys, I don't know if you like folks with talent. People are people who got them it. Let's just reload.
我要以掌声开始。我不知道。嘿，嘿，伙计们，我不知道。紧绷的神秘嘉宾。我们来了。我不知道如果嘿，伙计们，我不知道紧绷的神秘嘉宾。我们来了。我不知道如果你们喜欢伙计们。嘿，伙计们，我不知道如果你们喜欢有才华的人。人们是那些拥有它的人。让我们重新加载。
Here we come. Here we go. I don't know if you guys like folks with talent, period, but comma. That would be a comma. I don't know why I read these. Why do I write? I should just freestyle it like Willie. Hey guys. Hey guys. I don't know if you guys like folks with talent. People who are funny. Smart. This sounds insincere, but it is sincere, mystery guest.
我们来了。我们走吧。我不知道如果你们喜欢有才华的人，句号，但是逗号。那应该是个逗号。我不知道为什么我要读这些。我为什么要写？我应该像威利那样即兴发挥。嘿，伙计们。嘿，伙计们。我不知道如果你们喜欢有才华的人。那些有趣的人。聪明。这听起来不真诚，但它是真诚的，神秘嘉宾。
I don't know if you guys like folks with talent. Comment. People who are funny. Gotta get off the morning gummies. Charismatic. I don't take them till after four. Funny, smart, charismatic, and sparkly. I do. So I've invited one to join. You wrote what I do? I do.
我不知道如果你们喜欢有才华的人。逗号。那些有趣的人。得戒掉早上的软糖。有魅力。我直到四点以后才吃它们。有趣、聪明、有魅力，而且闪闪发光。我确实。所以我邀请了一位今天加入我们。她还不到40岁，但已经写了九部电影，导演了其中四部，主演了其中四部，并因此获得了三次奥斯卡提名。我敢打赌她的新片会有更多提名。她出生在萨克拉门托，但住在布鲁克林。她对舞蹈感兴趣，但在击剑方面很有竞争力。差点追求音乐剧，但最终在巴纳德学院获得了哲学学位，尽管有室友凯特·麦金农的破坏性和鲁莽影响。
So I've invited one to join us today. She's not yet 40, but she's already written nine movies, directed for them, starred in four of them, gotten three Academy Award nominations for them. And I'll bet there's more of those coming for her new one. She was born in Sacramento, but lives in Brooklyn. She was interested in dance, but was competitive in fencing. Almost pursued musical theater, but instead got a degree in philosophy from Barnard, Carla College, despite the destructive and reckless influence of dormate Kate McKinnon.
请欢迎格蕾塔·葛韦格小姐。格蕾塔！噢，什么？噢天哪。相当不错，对吧？那太棒了。那太棒了。那太棒了。
Please welcome Miss Greta Gerwig. Greta! Oh, what? Oh my God. Pretty good, right? That was amazing. That was amazing. It was great.
我在我可爱的小脚怪后面太紧张了。我很紧张。噢天哪。为什么？别紧张。噢天哪。我们是带着大量研究的硬核记者。是的。
I'm so nervous behind my little cute and big-footer. I'm nervous. Oh my God. Why? Don't be nervous. Oh my God. We're hard-hitting journalists with a lot of research. Yeah.
好的。我们要提出硬核问题。你可以看到我们非常认真地对待我们的工作。准备好了。我准备好了。准备好了，去吧，格蕾塔，很高兴见到你。是的，很高兴见到你。见到你也很高兴，我必须坦白。
Okay. And we're going to bring the hard hitting question. You can see we take our craft very seriously. Get ready. I'm ready. Ready, go right, get so nice to meet you. Yeah, great to meet you. It's so nice to meet you too and I have to confess.
我身后有个圆圈，我甚至不知道它存在。你被允许有关系。他们寄了一个给我。他们寄了一个。这就是我身后发生的事，我甚至不知道它存在。你被允许有真实的生活。他们寄了一个给我。他们寄了一个。这就是发生在我身上的事，格蕾塔。旁边那个是婴儿床吗？是的，是的，那是婴儿床。那是没有睡眠的地方。
I have a circle behind me, which I didn't even know existed. You're allowed to have relationships. And they sent one to me. They sent one. That's what happened behind me, which I didn't even know existed. You're allowed to have real life. And they sent one to me. They sent one. That's what happened to me, Greta. Is that a baby crib off to the side there? Yes, yes, that's a baby crib. That's where no sleep.
你知道，肖恩，他们不，他们不，他们不，他们放下婴儿。他们只说婴儿床。是的，好吧。他们不说婴儿床。是的，每个人都知道你在说婴儿床。但那是给你的。嗯，有些人可能会说，我觉得那是你的房子。不。不，格蕾塔有两个小男孩。
You know, Sean, they don't, they don't, they don't, they drop the baby. They just say crib. Yeah, okay. They don't say baby crib. Yeah, everybody knows how to say crib that you're talking about. But it's for you. Well, some people might say, I think it's your house. No. No, Greta's got two baby boys.
是的，还有一个13岁的继子。明白了，简单。所以你那边沉浸在睾丸激素里。这就是我制作《芭比》的原因。是的。是的。是的。不，这太棒了。
Yeah, and a stepson who's 13. Got it, easy. So you're swimming in testosterone over there. That's why I made Barbie. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No, it's great.
所以我从来没有，实际上，身边有一群男孩太有趣了。噢，我道歉。你能听到警笛声。你已经有麻烦了吗？你被起诉了吗？你是吗？不。是的。
So I never, I actually, having a bunch of boys around is so fun. Oh, and I'm apologizing. You can hear sirens. Are you already in trouble? Are you under indictment? Are you? No. Yeah.
我觉得。所以，所以你在曼哈顿。你有两个儿子和一个有趣的伴侣。是的。是的。我们叫他们有趣，对吧？是的。我们叫诺亚有趣，对吧？是的，是的，他很有趣。而且你有一部非常有趣的电影要上映。
I feel like. So, so you're in Manhattan. You have two sons and a fun partner. Yes. Yes. We call them a fun, right? Yes. We call it, we call Noah Fun, right? Yes, yes he's fun. And you've got a really fun movie coming out.
噢天哪，我喜欢这个东西的预告片。我知道我。它是新的吗？好吧，让我们，我们要谈谈那个。我们要从哪儿开始呢？让我们看看我有什么硬核问题。让我们重新开始。让我们回到开头。
Oh God, I love the trailers on this thing. I know me. Is it new? All right, let's, we're gonna get to that. Where are we gonna get started here? Let's see what kind of hardening question I got. Let's start it again. Let's go back to the beginning.
我想知道，我不，我遗憾地还不够了解你。我们太不擅长这个了，我遗憾地还不够了解你。她是个纯粹的舞者。我们太不擅长这个了，所以我们可能不会发现更多，因为我们没在谈论自己。但是什么？什么？
I wanna know, I don't, I sadly don't know enough about you yet. And we're so bad at this't, I sadly don't know enough about you yet. As she's a sheer dancer. We're so bad at this, so we probably won't find out more, because we're not talking about ourselves. But what? What?
我想知道，从你开始，当你还是个孩子的时候，什么，什么，你最被什么吸引？表演还是写作？或者你被吸引，因为是个出色的作家，你小时候就立刻被写作吸引了吗，比如你参加了创意艺术课什么的？嗯，我没有，我有点被整个事情吸引了。比如我在萨克拉门托长大，那里有一个非常健康和充满活力的社区剧院场景。所以我花了很多
I want to know like from when you start, when you were a kid, what was, what was, what were you drawn to most? The acting of the writing? Or were you drawn, because it's just a brilliant writer, were you drawn to writing right away as a kid, like were you like creative arts class or something? Well, I didn't, I was sort of drawn to the whole thing of it. Like I did grow up in Sacramento and there was a really healthy and vibrant community theater scene there. So I spent a lot of
时间去社区剧院并参与社区剧院，因为如果你喜欢，如果你喜欢它，那就是进入的方式。是的。现在，当你回顾你在社区剧院做的演出时，不会觉得，你知道，它们很棒，是很棒的经历，但就像高中一样。不，但那也是我认为我做过的最纯粹的艺术。是的。
time going to community theater and participating in community theater because if you liked if you liked it, that's sort of the way in. Yeah. And now, don't you look back when you, on the shows that you've done in community theater and be like, you know, they're great and great experience, but it's like, it's like high school. No, but it was also like sort of the purest art I think I've ever done. Yeah.
就像它是最，你知道，我认为我做过的。它是最，我不知道，有些东西真的很，就像每个人都有一个秘密的克拉克·肯特超人身份，一个代课老师，晚上可能是田纳西·威廉姆斯，谁知道呢。有些东西我一直觉得，我喜欢它。是的，我过去常为社区剧院的演出弹钢琴试镜。你是对的，你会得到，就像在等待戈多。
Like it's the most, you know, I think I've ever done. It's the most, I don't know, there's something like really, it's like everybody has a secret sort of like Clark Kent Superman identity, like a substitute teacher, might in the night to Tennessee Williams for all you know. There's something about that that I was always like, I love it. Yeah, I used to play auditions for piano for auditions for community theater shows. And you're right, you'd get, it was just like waiting for government.
就像人们，比如妈妈和爸爸和牙医，每个人都会进来。你没在萨克拉门托看到约瑟夫穿着他的技术外套，因为杰西卡·查斯坦在萨克拉门托看到了那个。她看到了？噢，那是对的。我想她在核桃溪剧院看到了，那是在外面。看，好吧。
It's like people like moms and dads and dentists and everybody would come in. You didn't see Joseph in the, in his technical code in Sacramento, because Jessica Chastain saw that in Sacramento. She did? Oh, that's right. Iastain saw that in Sacramento. She did? Oh, that's right. I think she saw it in the Walnut Creek Theater, which was, which was outside. See, okay.
我确实看到了，但有趣的事实是，我在杰西卡·查斯坦15或16岁时在社区剧院看到了她。没门。是的，我看到了她，在Shuttak剧院公司演《你不能把它带走》。她演芭蕾舞演员。我在，我在《你不能把它带走》里
I did see, but fun fact, I saw Jessica Chastain in community theater when she was like 15 or 16. No way. Yeah, and I saw her and you can't take it with you at the Shuttak with theater company. And she played the ballerina. I was in, I was in, you can't take it with you
高中时，只有一句台词。我是个联邦调查局探员，那是，你是对的，长官。他们在那儿有足够的火药把整个镇炸飞。那是我的唯一台词。对。我想你后来在高中演了《你不能把它带走》。我很想再拍一次那个，肖恩。让我们玩得开心点，后来在高中。我很想再拍一次那个，肖恩。
and high school and had one line. And I was a G-man and it was, you were a right chief. They have enough gunpowder down there to blow up the whole town. That was my only line. Right. I think you can't take it with you later in high school. I'd love to get one more take on that, Sean. Let's just have fun with it later in high school. I'd love to get one more take on that, Sean.
让我们玩得开心点。我们开始吧。还在录。你是对的，长官。他们在那儿没有足够的火药把整个镇炸飞。明白了。谢谢。检查。
Let's just have fun with it. Here we go. Still rolling. You're right, chief. They have not got a better down there to blow up the whole town. Got it. Thank you. Check it.
抱歉。那很酷。所以你去了，你去了《你不能把它带走》？还有什么？是的。我想我演了。这是，距离我上次看这部戏已经有一分钟了。里面有个俄罗斯女人吗？是的。因为我记得我是俄罗斯人。是的，是的。
Sorry. That's cool. So what were you went and so you were going to you can't take it with you? What else? Yeah. I think I played. Is this like it's been a minute since I've seen the play. Is there a Russian woman in it? Yes. Because I have a memory of being Russian. Yeah, yeah.
哇。是的。是的。如果不是的话，那是个大胆的选择。不。但它确实要开始，它确实以表演开始，然后什么时候转向写作的？嗯，我一直在写，但我真的没有……我不知道，真的没有出口……就我的高中和一切而言，没有像……这里是学生写的剧本。但他们确实让你做，比如……我写了返校集会的所有返校小品。那是我的方式，就像是个作家。
Wow. Yeah. Yeah. Is a bold choice if there wasn't. No. But it was so it was going to start with, it did start with acting and then when did it go to writing? Well, I was always writing, but I didn't really have... I didn't know that there wasn't really an outlet for... In terms of my high school and everything, there wasn't like... And here are the players who are students, I've written. But they did let you do like... I wrote all the homecoming sketches for homecoming rallies. That was my way of like being sort of a writer.
然后直到我实际上到了巴纳德学院，我正在上表演课，我正在写场景，我写了我自己的独白来试镜，他们说，那不是，你没被说服做那个。你得拿一个，是的。我说，噢，然后他们说，其中一位很棒的老师说，
And then it wasn't until actually I got to college at Barnard that I was taking an acting class and I was writing scenes and I wrote on my own monologue to audition and they were like, that's not, you're not convinced to do that. You gotta take one, yeah. And I was like, oh, and then they said, one of the teachers who was great was like,
我想你想上一门剧本写作课，然后我开始在大学里上剧本写作，那就像，噢，然后他们说，其中一位很棒的老师说，我想你想上一门剧本写作课。然后我开始在大学里上剧本写作，那就像一个瞬间。噢，哇。在萨克拉门托的什么点，或者什么，什么让你兴奋离开萨克拉门托？比如，你知道当你，你就像，我在这里受限了。我知道这里只有某个，你知道，我可以去的地方。嗯，我有，我爸爸实际上，他最好的朋友之一是哥伦比亚大学的数学教授。
I think you want to take a play writing class and then I started taking play writing in college and that was like, oh, and then they said one of the teachers who was great was like, I think you want to take a playwriting class. And then I started taking playwriting in college and that was like an instant. Oh, wow. What point in Sacramento or what, what got you excited to leave Sacramento? Like, did you know when you were, you're like, I'm limited here. I know there's only a certain, you know, place I can go here. Well, I had, my dad actually, one of his best friends was a mass professor at Columbia.
我五岁时去了纽约市。我有一个，只是一个非常强烈的记忆，等待百老汇演出的抢票。我看到了，我看到了，比如《吉普赛》里的Time Daily。我看到了《第42街》里的Jerry Urbach。所有的抢票，你，你坐在前排，直视上方。是的。
And we went to New York City when I was five. And I had a, just a really strong memory of waiting for like rush tickets for Broadway plays. And I saw, I saw like, time daily in Gypsy. And I saw Jerry Urbach in 42nd Street. And all the rush tickets, you're, you're sitting in the front row and looking sort of straight up. Yeah.
我记得我说，我得回到百老汇。那就是我感觉到的。我只是觉得，我这辈子都不能。那是89年。所以我还认为那是，那里仍然有像霓虹灯脱衣舞俱乐部和42街，还有一切。一切都像，我只是感兴趣。所以我有点把它记在心里，真的。
And I remember I was like, I gotta get back to Broadway. That's sort of what I felt. I just was like, I could never in my life. And it was the 89. So I also think it was like, there were still kind of like the neon strip bars and 42 streets and like everything. And everything was like, I just was interested. And I so I kind of had it in my mind for really.
它仍然有点肮脏，以那种方式有点令人兴奋。我记得我在出租车里说。我们有一次在出租车里，我对妈妈说，我有这个，带我去看什么？我五岁，我记得我有一套最喜欢的衣服，是粉红色的，上面全是吉他。我叫它我的摇滚乐衣服。我对妈妈说，我明天能穿我的摇滚乐衣服吗？出租车司机说，我会等你。我以后会娶你。我说，噢，这个要娶我，回想起来可能很恶心。是的，这很恶心。太棒了。他被捕了。那太棒了。他被捕了。
It was still kind of grimy and kind of like exciting in that way. And I remember I said in a cab. We were in a cab once and I said to my mom, I had this like, take me to look what? I was five and I remember I had a favorite outfit, I was pink and had guitars all over it. And I called it my rock and rock and roll outfit. And I said to my mom, I was like, can I wear my rock and roll outfit tomorrow? And the cab driver said, I'll wait for you. I'll marry you later. And I was like, oh, this is going to marry me, which they in retrospect was maybe gross. Yeah, it'll be gross. Amazing. He was arrested. That was amazing. He was arrested.
他被捕了。他的名字是诺亚·鲍姆巴赫。我们马上回来。SmartLess由BetterHelp赞助。所以，我在这里的百老汇演出即将结束。你知道，这是一次非常成功、有趣、令人难以置信的奖励经历。然后我要回家去洛杉矶，我想这会击中我。
He was arrested. And his name is Noah Bombay. And we will be right back. SmartLess is sponsored by BetterHelp. So it's just wrapping up my Broadway run here. And you know, it was a very successful, fun, incredibly rewarding experience. And then I'm going to go home to Los Angeles, and I think it's going to hit me.
我只会觉得，等等，我在这里做什么？我坐在沙发上。我没什么可做的。我是谁？你如何定义自己？如果你定义自己为演员，而你没在演戏，你是谁？对吧？那是我一直想的。
I'm just going to be like, wait, what am I doing here? I'm sitting on the couch. I'm nothing to do. Who am I? How do you define yourself? If you define yourself as an actor and you're not acting, who are you? Right? That's what I always think about.
就像那些你不工作的小间隙。你是谁？你做什么？所有那些我们问自己的空灵问题，对吧？有时在生活中，我们面临艰难的选择，前进的道路并不总是清晰的。无论你是在处理关于职业、关系还是其他任何事情的决定，治疗都能帮助你保持与你真正想要的联系，同时驾驭生活。这样你就可以带着自信和兴奋前进。相信自己做出决定
It's like those little gaps when you're not working. Who are you? What do you do? All of those kinds of ethereal questions that we ask ourselves, right? Sometimes in life, we're faced with tough choices and the path forward isn't always clear. Whether you're dealing with decisions around career, relationships or anything else, therapy helps you stay connected to what you really want while you navigate life. So you can move forward with confidence and excitement. Trusting yourself to make decisions
符合你的价值观就像任何事情一样。你练习得越多，它就变得越容易。我从治疗中受益匪浅。你们总是听到我谈论它。我相信当我回家时，我会和我的治疗师提起这个话题。她太棒了。她总是会给我很好的建议。
that align with your values is like anything. The more you practice it, the easier it gets. I've benefited from therapy like crazy. You guys always hear me talk about it. And I'm sure I'm gonna bring this topic up with my therapist when I get home. And she's fantastic. She's always gonna give me great advice.
所以如果你正在考虑开始治疗，给BetterHelp一个机会。如果你正在考虑开始治疗，给BetterHelp一个机会。它完全在线，设计得方便、灵活，适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与持证治疗师匹配，并随时免费更换治疗师。让治疗成为你的地图，使用BetterHelp。
So if you're thinking of starting therapy, give better help, a try. It if you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with the licensed therapist and switch therapists any time for no additional charge. Let therapy be your map with BetterHelp.
今天访问betterhelp.com/smartless，首次购买可享受10%的折扣。那是betterhelp.com/smartless。我们部分由ZipRecruiter带给您。你知道，我有一个比很多人知道的鲜为人知的才华。我会做饭。我不是什么伟大的厨师，但我会做一些让你大吃一惊的东西。比如，比如，Sloppy Joes。
Visit betterhelp.com slash smartless today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelphlp.com slash smartless. We're brought to you in part by Zip Recruiter. You know, I have a lesser known talent than a lot of people know. I can cook stuff. I'm not like a great chef, but I will make stuff that will blow your mind. And like, for example, sloppy joes.
我有最棒的旧式Sloppy Joes。我有最棒的旧式Sloppy Joe食谱，我会保密。但那需要很多工作。它有大量的配料什么的，它不仅仅是来自罐头。比如我是从零开始做的，伙计们。所以我只是想说，从软技能
I have the greatest old, sloppy joes. I have the greatest old school sloppy joe recipe that I'm gonna keep at secret. But it's a lot of work. It has like tons of ingredients and stuff in it that it's not just from a can. Like I make it from scratch people. So I just wanted to say from like soft skills
到硬技能，比如做Sloppy Joe，需要各种各样的才华才能使企业成功，特别是如果你要开一家Sloppy Joe餐厅的话。如果你正在招聘，并且想为你的空缺职位找到合适的人才组合，你需要ZipRecruiter。现在你可以在zipprecruiter.com/smartless免费试用。ZipRecruiter如何为你的职位找到最合适的人选？ZipRecruiter使用强大的技术来寻找并向你发送技能和经验与你的工作匹配的人。
to hard skills like sloppy Joe making, it takes all kinds of talent to make a business successful, especially if you're going to open a restaurant of sloppy Joe's. If you're hiring and you want to find the right combination of talent for your open roles, you need Zippercrooter. And right now you can try it for free at zippercrooter.com slash smartless. How does Zippercrooter find the most spot on people for your roles? Zippercrooter uses powerful technology to find and send you people whose skills and experience match your job.
如果你看到你真正感兴趣的人，ZipRecruiter让你轻松邀请他们申请你的工作，以增加你在竞争对手之前获得他们的机会。难怪330万家企业来到ZipRecruiter寻求招聘需求。利用ZipRecruiter寻找优秀候选人的无与伦比的才华。在ZipRecruiter上发布职位的雇主中，五分之四在第一天内就获得了高质量的候选人。亲自看看。
If you see someone you're really interested in, zippercrooter lets you easily invite them to apply to your job to increase your chances of getting them before your competition does. No wonder 3.3 million businesses have come to Zippercuder for their hiring needs. Tap into Zippercuder's unmatched talent for finding great candidates. Four out of five employers who post on Zippercuder get a quality candidate within the first day. See for yourself.
前往这个独家网址免费试用ZipRecruiter，ziprecruiter.com/smartless。再说一次，那是ziprecruiter.com/SMART-LESS ZipRecruiter.com/smart. L-E-S-S ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。SmartLess由Smartwater赞助。所以，你知道，现在是夏天。外面太他妈热了。
Go to this exclusive web address to try Zippercuder for free, ziprecuder.com slash smartless. Again, that's ziprecuder.com slash SMART-LESS Zippercuderuder.com slash smart. L-E-S-S zippercruder, the smartest way to hire. Smartless is sponsored by smart water. So, you know, it's summer right now. It's so effing hot outside.
每个人都感觉到了。无论你去哪里，我们都在打破记录。太热了，太热了，太热了。给身体补水非常重要。很多时候，当夏天很热时，每个人都喜欢出去喝酒，对吧？你去酒吧，你闲逛，你去派对，你喝酒，这让你更脱水。所以现在你在外面，你在喝啤酒，
Everybody feels it. Everywhere you go, we're breaking records. It's hot, hot, hot. It's so important to hydrate your body. And a lot of the times when it's summer and it's hot, everybody likes to go out and drink, right? You go to bars, you hang out, you go to parties, and you drink, which makes you more dehydrated. So now you're outside, you're drinking a beer,
或者葡萄酒，或者鸡尾酒，或者其他什么，它让你随着热量变得更脱水。所以你得补水，伙计们。去派对，但要补水，对吧？Smartwater。在这里的播客上，我们是Smartless，但不是Smartwaterless。Smartwater是100%蒸汽蒸馏的，口感纯净清脆。它pH平衡，并提供添加的电解质以增加口感。
or wine, or a cocktail, or whatever, and it's making you more dehydrated along with the heat. So you gotta hydrate, folks. Go party, but hydrate, right? Smart water. Here on the podcast, we are smartless, but not smart waterless. Smart water is 100% vapor distilled with a pure crisp taste. It's pH balanced and offers added electrolytes for taste.
所以对我来说，现在，我正要出门。我要去剧院走很长一段路。我要拿一瓶Smartwater，它会起作用。它会给我的身体补水。这里写着，我们不允许说Smartwater让你更聪明，但我们可以说它适合在你听你最喜欢的播客时啜饮，当然。
So for me, right now, I'm headed out the door. I'm going for a long walk to the theater. I'm gonna grab a smart water, and it's gonna work. It's going to hydrate my body. And it says here, we're not allowed to say that smart water makes you smarter, but we can say it's for sip and while you're listening to your favorite podcast, of course.
用Smartwater保持聪明。现在回到节目。所以如果我是个年轻作家，我想，一个有抱负的作家，你会建议写剧本还是在开始处理长片格式之前尝试写像对话场景的东西？嗯，我认为它非常有用，就比如，做起来非常便宜，就比如看到
Keep it smart with smart water. And now back to the show. So if I'm a young writer and I want a, an aspiring writer, would you recommend writing plays or trying to write like a dialogue scene before you start to take on sort of the formatting of a feature and stuff like that? Well, I think it's really useful just in terms of like, it's very cheap to do in terms of like seeing
它如何与演员合作。你知道，我……因为你的对话太棒了，太简单了，太自然了，太，然而，你也在说些什么，比如那是个很棒的小技巧，对吧？你有东西，嗯，人们实际上是那样说话的，但然后你有点像特洛伊木马一样塞进了一些实际上相当深刻的东西，比如，噢天哪，我意识到我现在在哭，你知道，或者在笑，比如你让它看起来非常非常容易。格蕾塔，那也停止偷偷塞进信息了吗？是的，你知道我的意思吗？
how it works with actors. You know, I... Because your dialogue is so great, it's so easy, it's so natural, it's so yet, you're also saying something, like that's a great little trick, right? You have something, well, people actually talk like that, but then you sort of trojan horse in something actually pretty profound and like, oh my god, and I've realized I'm now crying and, you know, or laughing and like you make it seem very, very easy. And did that also stop sneaking messages in, Greta? Yeah, you know what I mean?
你知道，我们需要很多。我们不能，我们受不了。我们太敏感了。所以，很多来自尝试，与，与，与成为剧作家，并用它做大部分对话。不要一个人。是的。我的意思是，我会，我想实际上做社区剧院或在学校做剧院也是背诵非常棒的文本，即使是在像场景课里。太棒了，因为它让你意识到为什么它很棒，因为它，我不知道，我没有作为演员经历过那么多次，但我记得，比如做，我不知道，莎士比亚或田纳西·威廉姆斯或爱德华·阿尔比或类似的东西，当文本有点向你敞开时，你意识到，你可以
You know, we need much for us. We don't, we can't take it. We're too sensitive. So, a lot of that come from trying with, with, with being a playwright and, and doing mostly dialogue with that. Not to be alone. Yeah. I mean, I will, I think I actually doing community theater or doing theater at school was also memorizing really great text, even in like scene classes. amazing because it kind of makes you realize why it's great is because it I don't know I haven't had this experience that many times as an actor but like I remember like doing you know I don't know Shakespeare or Tone of Williams or Edward Albuy or something like that when the text sort of opens up to you and you realize like you could
在这个角色上做很多决定，它们都是对的，因为它很丰富，而且它有点饱满，它就在那里为你准备着，我想我当时想，噢，如果能找到让演员感到自由而不是受约束的词，那对演员来说是个礼物，是的，对我来说，再次写作，一切都在大学里，真的很幸运。我的一位剧本写作教授说，因为我们都会读彼此的作品，而且凯特·麦金农当时也和我同时在做剧本写作课。是的，等等，不坏，她是个问题，她是麻烦。我真的很高兴你远离了她。
make so many decisions at this kid as this character and they're all right because it's rich and it's sort of full and it's there for you and I think I was like oh that's a gift to an actor if you can kind of find words that makes them feel free and not constrained and yeah for me writing again it was all in college, it was really lucky. One of my play writing professors was like because we'd all read each other's work and also Kate McKinnon was she was also doing play writing classes with me at the same time. Yeah wait no bad, she's a problem, she's trouble. I'm really glad you got away from her.
等等，所以那是在杰森的介绍里，你们是室友？是的，是的，我们去了，嗯，她在哥伦比亚的介绍里。你们是室友？是的，是的。我们去了，嗯，她在哥伦比亚，我在巴纳德，然后我们最终，你知道，我不知道，你喜欢一起去租房，你知道，那是那件事吗？她试图把你拉进去，对吧，带你走那条路，好，好为你，你远离了她。她一直，比如，我见过的最有趣、最有才华的人。而且什么都擅长。太有趣了，我得到了很多。而且我也看到她演戏剧。
Wait, so that was in Jason's intro, you were roommates? Yeah, yeah we went, well she was at Columbia's intro. You were roommates? Yeah, yeah. We went, well, she was at Columbia and I was at Barnard and then we ended up, you know, I don't know, you like go in for housing together, you know, was that thing? She tried to pull you in, right, and take you down the path and good, good for you that you stayed away. She was always the, like, the funniest, most talented person I'd ever met. And good at everything. So funny, I got so much. And I also saw her do drama.
她什么都能做。她就像梅丽尔·斯特里普。她太不真实了。是的，但我们会一起上这些剧本写作课。你大声读彼此的作品。然后我们的老师组织了真正的专业演员来读我们的剧本，那就像……真正的专业演员？
She could do anything. She was like, Meryl Streep. She was unreal. And yeah, but we would do these playwriting classes together. And you read each other's work out loud. And then our teacher organized for real professional actors to come read our plays, which was like... Real professional actors?
真正的专业演员。那个演员，我不知道你是否认识他，他是个很棒的演员，迈克尔·切尔尼斯。当然。是的。他太棒了。他读了我的剧本。我当时19岁，他太棒了。
Real professional actors. And the actor, I don't know if you know him, he's a wonderful actor, Michael Churnis. Sure. Yeah. He's amazing. And he read my play. And I was like 19 and he was amazing.
我觉得我是最好的作家，因为他让它变得更美妙。我当时就像，这太令人兴奋了。我的意思是，我看到一个问题。你已经在你的电影中选用了迈克尔·切尔尼斯了吗？实际上，是的，是的。我不知道。很高兴你叫破了杰森的虚张声势。好。我叫了美国先生，我们选用了他，我告诉他，我说，你记得秋天去巴纳德学院吗？他说，噢天哪，那是你。这太疯狂了。你知道，我昨天刚看到马特·达蒙的采访，谈到他写《心灵捕手》时，他在大学里写那个作为，他正在写，他正在做，比如，他们必须写独幕剧，他谈到他写了那个40分钟的东西，
And I thought I was the best writer because he like made it even more wonderful. I was like the it was so exciting. I mean, I see a question. Have you cast Michael churnes in one of your films yet? Actually, yes, yes. I don't know. Good for you to call Jason's bluff. Good. I called Mr. America and we cast him and I told him I was like, do you remember coming to Barnard College one fall? And he said, oh my God, that was you. That's so crazy. You know, I just saw an interview yesterday with Matt Damon talking about when he wrote Goodwill Hunting and he wrote that in college as a, he was writing, he was doing like a, they had to write one act plays and he was talking about the fact that he wrote this sort of 40 minute thing and
他对他的教授说，我想我失败了，因为我有这个东西，我不知道它是什么，但我认为也许它是剧本，然后他最终把它拿回来和本一起写，有趣的是谈论本看着它说，我认为我们应该一起研究这个的过程。然后谈论作为年轻作家的发现，去，本对他说，比如，如果你的角色说这个，我认为另一个人应该说这个。然后拥有，正如你所知，作为作家，其中很多只是那样，对吧，只是在那些时刻相信你的直觉，比如理解你是谁，谁是那个
he says to his professor, I think I failed because I've got this thing and I don't know what it is, but I think maybe it's a screenplay and then he ended up taking it back and writing with Ben and what was interesting was talking about the process of then Ben looking at it going, I think we should work on this together. And then talking about the discovery as young writers and going and Ben saying to him, like, if your character says this, I think the other guy should say this. And then having, and as you know, as a writer that so much of it is just that, right, is just trusting your instinct in those moments of like understanding who you're, who that
角色，然后去。我认为对年轻作家大声说出来非常有价值。那个过程确实是那样，对吧？并拥有信心。我们就像查克·马丁过去常说的，对吧？写作只是说话。那是查克·马丁吗？吉姆·瓦利。吉姆·瓦利。是的，伟大的吉姆·瓦利。不，这就是我的意思，我认为它是。
character is and going. And I thought it was very valuable to say out loud to young writers. Just that process is really that right? And having the confidence. We're like Chuck Martin used to say right? Writing's just talking. Was that Chuck Martin? Jim Valley. Jim Valley. Yeah, the great Jim Valley. No, that's all I mean, I think it is.
我一直说，你知道，我可能从某人那里偷了这个，但比如写作和倾听，你必须有点，那是你，你必须有点听角色互相说话。而且，我认为，以一种有趣的方式，或者对我来说，导演，比如，我不能，对我来说，写作过程和导演过程是不同的。它们非常分离。我真的不想导演什么，直到我觉得剧本很好，而且值得做。
I always said, you know, I'm probably stealing this from someone, but like writing and listening, you have to sort of, that was you, you kind of have to listen to the characters talk to each other. And, and I think, in a funny way, or for me anyway, directing, like, I can't, for me, the writing process and the directing process are different. They're very separated. And I don't really want to direct something until I feel like the script is good and like worse doing.
我总是说，你知道，我可能是从别人那里偷来的这句话，但写作和倾听，你必须，那是你，你必须倾听角色之间的对话。而且，我觉得，有趣的是，或者至少对我来说，导演，我无法，对我而言，写作过程和导演过程是不同的。它们是完全分开的。在我觉得剧本足够好且值得拍摄之前，我真的不想去导演任何东西。
And I think because of a kind of separate person in my brain, there's times as a director where I'm like, I knew something as a writer a year ago, or a six months ago, which I don't know anymore. And I sort of have to trust the writer part of me that they knew what they were doing and not tinker with it later. Like any edits I've done in the directing process, I've always regretted.
我觉得因为我大脑里有一个相对独立的人格，作为导演，有时我会觉得，我作为编剧在一年前或六个月前知道的一些东西，现在已经不知道了。我必须信任作为编剧的那部分自己，相信他们当时知道自己在做什么，而不是事后去乱改。比如我在导演过程中做的任何修改，我事后都后悔了。
I've always gone back to the original script and like, what was I trying to do? Yeah, you know, it's funny. You write, I imagine you always write alone, right? You write by yourself only. Unless I write with Noah, he's the only one who's on the right with Noah. So you do write with Noah. Yeah, because I write with chapter.
我总是会回到最初的剧本，问自己：我当时想表达什么？是啊，这很有趣。你写作，我想你总是独自写作，对吧？你只一个人写。除非我和诺亚一起写，他是唯一一个和我一起写的人。所以你确实和诺亚一起写。是的，因为我和查皮一起写。
I talk about, I know, I bring up Chappy, but once in an episode. And I find, I get so much value for me. Now he writes, he writes some stuff on his own as well, but he and I write together and I get so much value out of those conversations and those moments. So that later, when we do stuff and when we actually shoot stuff that we've, that we've got each other to go back on and go like, wait, what was, I think, what were we thinking in that moment? And one of us will catch the other one and go, we're doing it because bubble blinding does make sense. And I think we are right on this.
我提到过，我知道，我提到了查皮，但一集只提一次。我发现，我从中获得了巨大的价值。现在他也会自己写一些东西，但他和我一起写，我从那些对话和时刻中获益良多。所以后来，当我们做事情，当我们真正拍摄我们写的东西时，我们有彼此可以依靠，可以问：等等，我们当时在想什么？我们中的一个会提醒另一个说：我们这么做是因为……这说不通。我觉得我们在这一点上是对的。
You need that, you need that sounding. Yeah, it's kind of what you're talking about a little bit. Exactly. Well, Greta, what about when the directing, do you let the directing win over the writing or is it the other way around me? You may have just answered this, but like what if while you're directing something, you fear, oh, you know what, we're actually saying that with this performance or saying that with this camera shot so we don't actually need to literally say it, let's cut the line.
你需要那个，你需要那个共鸣。是的，这有点像你刚才说的。没错。那么，格蕾塔，当导演工作和写作发生冲突时，你是让导演的意图胜出，还是反过来？你可能刚才已经回答了，但如果你在执导某场戏时担心：哦，你知道吗，我们其实可以通过表演或镜头语言表达出来，所以不需要真的说出来，那我们把这句台词删掉吧。
Yeah, yeah, I mean, I feel like it's not really the like director side of me wins as much as when you kind of expose it all to air and bring actors in. I think it's often more that I feel that the actor, usually I shoot what's on the page. I'm pretty good up. I'm like, well, you know, but then often because I've gotten to work with such great actors, you find that the actor has done it without, you know, you've written all these lines and the actor, the audience knows right away what the actor is feeling. They're communicating it anyway. But yeah, it's really with like actors that I feel like it changes. Right.
是啊，是啊，我觉得并不是导演那一面胜出，而是当你把一切都摊开，让演员加入时。我觉得更多时候是我感觉到演员……通常我拍的是剧本上的内容。我做得还不错。我心想，好吧，你知道的，但通常因为我能和这么棒的演员合作，你会发现演员在没有台词的情况下也做到了，你知道，你写了所有这些台词，但观众立刻就能感受到演员的情绪。他们无论如何都在传达。但确实，我觉得和演员在一起时，情况会发生变化。没错。
What interests me is, so I have it, I've said like everybody else, I've seen the trailer for Barbie and haven't seen it yet, but it looks amazing. And it's so visually, first of all, visually, it's so stunning. There's so much to look at. And so I'm curious because I've never worked on something like that before where there is such a visual element to it That how you approach that as you're writing it how much of that ends up on the page and if you're directing You don't really have to explain it. Although you do have to
我感兴趣的是，我和其他人一样，看过《芭比》的预告片，还没看过正片，但看起来太棒了。首先，视觉上，它太震撼了。有很多值得看的东西。所以我很好奇，因为我以前从未参与过这种有如此强烈视觉元素的作品，你在写作时是如何处理的？有多少视觉内容会写在剧本上？如果你是导演，你其实不需要解释它。虽然你确实需要……
Walk everybody else through it, right a little bit In some ways it was on the yeah, there were things on the page in a sort of general sense But I found that for Barbie in particular it was I had a very long time working with a production designer before, I mean, I think I started talking to the production designer in the book, at least a year before we started shooting. Oh, wow. And this DP, at least a year, and the same with the custom designer. And so a lot of the things that got worked out in the movie
引导其他人了解它，对吧？在某种程度上，剧本里确实有一些通用的描述，但我发现对于《芭比》来说，我在拍摄前和美术指导合作了很长时间，我想我在开拍前至少一年就开始和美术指导沟通了。哦，哇。还有摄影指导，至少一年，服装设计师也是。所以电影中很多最终呈现出来的东西……
were things that came out of just like tons of meetings, of like how even things like, you know, there's these incredible sets they built. And they also do. It was like a combination of like large scale sets that are on these sound stages. And then also we built a lot of miniatures, which was amazing and I've never built miniatures,
都是经过无数次会议讨论出来的，比如那些他们搭建的令人难以置信的布景。他们确实做到了。这就像是摄影棚里的大型布景和我们搭建的许多微缩模型的结合，这太棒了，我以前从未做过微缩模型，
but I love them, like those pictures of like when they were making, you know, Star Wars or if you watch the like, I-L-M documentary, you're like, all I wanna do is glue little things. Did you see what that star? Did you watch the ILM documentary? I love the ILM.
但我很喜欢它们，就像那些制作《星球大战》时的照片，或者如果你看了工业光魔（ILM）的纪录片，你会想：我只想粘一些小东西。你看过那个吗？你看过工业光魔的纪录片吗？我爱死工业光魔了。
It's incredible. Incredible. Incredible. It's like my favorite. Those guys are like, I hate you. Unbelievable. Love them. And they're all so special.
太不可思议了。太不可思议了。太不可思议了。那简直是我的最爱。那些家伙简直让我嫉妒。难以置信。爱死他们了。他们都太特别了。
I don't know. And they were all like in college, just like in a warehouse going like, let's make this. Well, we can't make that. There's no, it doesn't exist. Well, let's build it. Well, what? And they just built a camera that makes it do what you want to do. It's just phenomenal. It's so, so, like, I think it's so, doesn't exist. Well, let's build it. Well, what and then just build the camera that makes it do what you want to do It's just phenomenal. It's also like I think it's also I mean
我不知道。他们当时都在上大学，就在一个仓库里说：我们来做这个吧。好吧，我们做不了那个。没有，它不存在。好吧，那我们把它造出来。什么？他们就造了一台能实现他们想要的摄像机。这简直太神奇了。我觉得这太……它不存在。好吧，那我们把它造出来。什么？然后就造了一台能实现你想要的摄像机。这简直太神奇了。我觉得这也……我是说……
I have to say like in terms of documentary is about making things Disney plus is killing it. They've got the ILM doc and also That get back the Beatles doc. Yes, and did you see the did you see the Pixar doc? No, that's incredible. Did you guys see the doc about the Pixar doc? Yeah, they did a doc about the making of the Pixar doc. Wait, credit, since we're on the Barbie thing, I just have to ask the obvious question. First of all, when somebody approached you or did you come up with the idea, how did
我必须说，就关于制作东西的纪录片而言，Disney+做得太棒了。他们有工业光魔的纪录片，还有披头士的《Get Back》纪录片。是的，你看过皮克斯的纪录片吗？不，那太不可思议了。你们看过关于皮克斯纪录片的纪录片吗？是的，他们拍了一部关于制作皮克斯纪录片的纪录片。等等，格蕾塔，既然我们在聊《芭比》，我必须问一个显而易见的问题。首先，当有人联系你，或者你是怎么想到这个主意的？
it happen? And weren't you because someone like me sitting back was like they're making Barbie a movie, like a live-action movie, and then you see the trailer, you're like, oh my god, this is so cool. But at first, weren't you like, wait, what? Well, actually, it was Margot Robbie invited me into this because she is a producer,
它是怎么发生的？而且你当时难道没有……因为像我这样的人坐在后面会想：他们要拍《芭比》电影，真人电影？然后你看到预告片，你会觉得：天哪，这太酷了。但起初，你难道没有想过：等等，什么？其实是玛格特·罗比邀请我加入的，因为她是制片人，
and I had met her a few years earlier, and I mean, I loved her as an actor, and then when I talked to her as a producer and I met her a few years earlier and I loved her as an actor and then when I talked to her as a producer, she's really wonderful and smart and everything you hope a producer can be. So she got the rights and was going to make it and she came to me and said, would you be interested in writing it? And then I, that was like shortly after the birth of my first child. And I must have said, yes, and I'd like know it or write it too. Which then later she kind of was like, why am I writing a Barbie movie with you? Just a Ken part.
我几年前见过她，我是说，我作为演员很喜欢她，然后当我以制片人的身份和她交谈时……我几年前见过她，我作为演员很喜欢她，然后当我以制片人的身份和她交谈时，她真的很棒、很聪明，是你希望制片人具备的一切特质。所以她拿到了版权，打算制作这部电影，她来找我问：你有兴趣写剧本吗？那是在我第一个孩子出生后不久。我肯定说了：好，我也想写。后来她有点纳闷：为什么我要和你一起写《芭比》电影？只是肯的部分吗？
And I was like, yeah, it's going to be great. And he was like, what are we going to do? That's, I don't know. And so, but then I sort of had a, I don't know. I just had a feeling about it. Mostly I had a feeling about Margo. And it sort of seemed so outrageous. I thought, well, I don't know.
我说：是啊，这会很棒。他说：我们要拍什么？我不知道。但后来我有一种感觉。主要是对玛格特的感觉。这看起来太离谱了，我想，好吧，我不知道。
It could be interesting. And then, and then Noah and I started writing it. Really, we started writing at March of 2020. So it's very much shut down. Yeah. Time. And then anyway, I didn't know I was going to direct it until we were done writing the script.
这可能会很有趣。然后，诺亚和我开始写了。真的，我们是2020年3月开始写的。所以当时正处于封锁期间。是的。时间。总之，在写完剧本之前，我并不知道我会执导它。
And I was like, well, I really like this. And I don't want anyone else to do it. And what is, any fears about it? Like any fears about like? Like any fears about like... Well, so many fears. I have, I have as fears. I still have fears. So fears are continuing.
然后我想：好吧，我真的很喜欢这个。我不希望别人来拍。有什么担心的吗？比如有什么恐惧吗？比如有什么恐惧吗……嗯，有很多恐惧。我有，我有恐惧。我现在还有恐惧。所以恐惧还在继续。
No, no, it's, it's, it's a, yeah, it's a terrifying. How, you and Noah are both incredibly good at keeping things real, keeping things smart, sophisticated, nuanced, blah, blah, blah, all the things that you would not think of first when you think of Barbie, which is for kids and something that is, I think, by design, supposed to be very sort of base and primary. Was there a, I'm sure there was a very interesting discussion between you and him was there a, I'm sure there was a very interesting discussion between you and him about,
不，不，这，这，这太可怕了。你和诺亚都非常擅长保持真实、保持聪明、复杂、细腻，等等，所有这些你在想到《芭比》时不会第一时间想到的东西，因为它是给孩子看的，而且我认为，设计上它应该是很基础和原始的。你和他之间肯定有过非常有趣的讨论，你和他之间肯定有过非常有趣的讨论，关于……
okay, how are we going to take something that is really sort of, again, generic by design and putting all the stuff that we're really good at and known for? Was that an exciting kind of opposite situation for you guys? Well, thank you for all of that. I mean, yeah, I guess I've, I've always feel like there's something exciting about things that appear unlikely, or things that appear sort of like, how's that gonna work, you know,
好吧，我们要如何把一个本质上很普通的东西，融入我们擅长且闻名的那些特质？这对你们来说是一种令人兴奋的相反情况吗？好吧，谢谢你的夸奖。我是说，是的，我想我一直觉得那些看起来不太可能的事情，或者看起来像“这怎么行得通”的事情，有些令人兴奋的地方，
or I think that sometimes those are where really interesting stuff comes from. And I think part of that has to do with because of honestly community theater, just doing, like sort of like, well, we're going to do it with what we've got. Let's go. But, you know, and I think that kind of, I don't know, it's like that challenge of finding your way into something that seems kind of like this is an odd. Right.
或者我认为有时真正有趣的东西就来自那里。我想这部分原因是因为社区剧院，就是那种“好吧，我们就用手头有的东西来做。开始吧。”但是，你知道，我认为那种，我不知道，就像那种挑战，找到进入一个看起来很奇怪的东西的方法。没错。
Look, everybody's got a preconceived notion of what that is, kind of what you were saying, Jay. Like, everybody's got this idea. Barbie is this, et cetera. We all have. And so by taking something that we all have such a relationship with or we have a preconceived notion about. Yeah.
看，每个人对它都有先入为主的观念，就像你说的，杰伊。每个人都有这种想法。芭比就是这样，等等。我们都有。所以通过选择一个我们都有这种关系或先入为主观念的东西。是的。
Yeah. Like, you guys are so incredibly good at writing stuff that is very sort of adult or questions that adults are capable of processing. I would imagine the studio was keen on keeping intact an appeal for children with this, yet you and Noah are both so great and known for the other. And so was there a negotiation with the studio about kind of merging the two, or were you
是的。你们非常擅长写那种非常成人化，或者成年人能够处理的问题。我想制片厂一定很想保持对儿童的吸引力，但你和诺亚都以擅长其他风格而闻名。所以，你们和制片厂之间是否有关于融合这两者的谈判，还是你们
and no excited about kind of just doing that even without asking them? Well, I mean, I think from the outset, we knew we were going to make a PG-13 movie so that it wasn't exactly, I mean, it wasn't like, you know, a hard-ar, or anything. Or a soft PG. Yeah, it's like a PG-13 could kind of occupy that space. I mean, I think also the movies, you know, I love a lot of PG-13 movies. And when I think about certain, like, I don't know, like, even like, Clueless, which was a big one for me, is like, I didn't understand a lot of those jokes, but I also loved it and thought it was hilarious and great.
和诺亚很兴奋，即使不问他们也想这么做？嗯，我是说，我想从一开始我们就知道我们要拍一部PG-13的电影，所以它并不完全是，我是说，它不像那种硬R级电影。或者温和的PG级。是的，PG-13可以占据那个空间。我是说，我也认为这些电影，你知道，我喜欢很多PG-13电影。当我想到某些电影时，比如《独领风骚》，那对我来说很重要，我当时并不理解很多笑话，但我依然很喜欢它，觉得它非常搞笑和棒。
And I felt like there was a way to do something that's kind of sophisticated and broad in that way. But the truth is, we really just amused ourselves and wrote something that we loved. And again, because of the pandemic, there was a real sense of like, I don't even know if any of this is like, like possible. Like, I don't know if we're going to go back to the movie theaters. And I think in a way, it sort of freed us. Also because it was Barbie, we were like, let's just go for broke. Let's make the craziest, most unmakeable thing we can write. And then see what happens. And it was, there was no kind of sense of like needing to
我觉得有一种方法可以做一些既复杂又通俗的事情。但事实是，我们真的只是自娱自乐，写了一些我们喜欢的东西。而且再次因为疫情，有一种真实的感觉，就像：我甚至不知道这一切是否可能。我不知道我们是否还能回到电影院。我觉得在某种程度上，它解放了我们。也因为它是《芭比》，我们想：让我们孤注一掷吧。让我们写出最疯狂、最不可思议的东西。然后看看会发生什么。没有那种需要
please anyone. And you also didn't think that you were going to be stuck with directing it either at the time. They were like, well, let's just write something that we both like and we don't have to direct it. Exactly. I was like, well, this is somebody else's problem. Right. Somebody else has to figure out how to build all this stuff and then like, and you're absolutely not able to fake this, but like, I didn't need to make a Barbie movie. I was like, well, I want to make this one. And if you guys don't want to make this one, then I don't. And then I, and then you hire Rodrigo Prieto, it was like, like, I mean, the movie is so again by design, perfectly perfectly colorful and flat and bright. And he's like an incredible cinematographer that can shape the best of him.
取悦任何人的感觉。而且当时你也没想到自己会被困在导演的位置上。他们当时说：好吧，让我们写一些我们都喜欢的东西，我们不必执导它。没错。我当时想：好吧，这是别人的问题。没错。别人得去想办法搭建所有这些东西，而且你绝对无法伪造这一点，但我不需要拍《芭比》电影。我当时想：好吧，我想拍这一部。如果你们不想拍这一部，那我就不拍了。然后，然后你雇了罗德里戈·普列托，这就像……我是说，这部电影再次通过设计，完美地色彩鲜艳、平坦且明亮。他是一位不可思议的摄影师，能塑造出他最好的一面。
Was he excited to do something that was completely opposite from what he's known for or to? Well, he's always been a dream DP for me to work with. I mean, he really lights with Godfingers. He's got one of those abilities. And he's just extraordinary. And I approached him about doing this. Not, I sent him the script and I said, you know, and he thought it was funny and he was interested. We started talking and he just,
他是否很兴奋能做一些与他闻名领域完全相反的事情？嗯，他一直是我梦想合作的摄影指导。我是说，他真的用上帝之手打光。他有那种能力。他简直太非凡了。我联系他做这件事。不是，我把剧本寄给他，我说：你知道，他觉得很有趣，他很感兴趣。我们开始交谈，他只是……
I mean, it was, he just, It's funny. I'm, it was, he just, it's funny, I'm imagining his face as he opens up the envelope and it just says, barb, yeah. And then he's like, page one, screaming at his agent, yeah. But he was like, we started working on it right after he finished shooting killers of the flower moon with Scruise A.V.
我是说，他只是……这很有趣。我，我能想象他打开信封时的表情，上面只写着“芭比”，是的。然后他看第一页，对他经纪人尖叫，是的。但他当时……我们在他拍完马丁·斯科塞斯的《花月杀手》后就开始着手了。
And it took me a full week to like, I had to like step aside with him and we were shot listing and talking and working on things. And I was like, Rodrigo, I'm having a lot of trouble because I just have to look at you and say, okay, so then Barbie is going to walk through it. Like I could, I was like, I'm like, I'm the beach. And she was like, I wanna be here.
我花了一整周的时间，我不得不和他单独坐下来，我们列出拍摄清单，讨论并处理事情。我说：罗德里戈，我遇到了很多麻烦，因为我必须看着你说：好吧，那么芭比要走过去。我能，我当时就像：我就是海滩。她说：我想在这里。
I wanna be doing this. And he's like, I could, I was like, I'm the beach. And she was like, I wanna be here, I wanna be doing this. And he's like, Greg, I have a question. When you're on set or what, are you guys, are you ever open to actors changing lines? Are you like, if an actor's like, you know what, I don't know that I would, I do fight back, you like just say the lines is written.
我想做这个。他说：我能，我当时就像：我就是海滩。她说：我想在这里，我想做这个。他说：格蕾塔，我有个问题。当你在片场时，或者什么，你们，你们是否愿意让演员改台词？如果演员说：你知道吗，我不知道我会不会那样做，你会反击吗？你喜欢让他们照着剧本说吗？
I promise for what? You show your mouth that way. I'm sure you're not that way. I'm sure you're not that way. You show your mouth that way. I hear you say that. I written. I promise. What? You know your mouth that way. You know how to say that? No. I hear you say that. I don't say that. But I do, I try to do as much as I can build in rehearsal because I find that I like,
我保证……什么？你那样说。我肯定你不是那样的人。我肯定你不是那样的人。你那样说。我听你这么说。我写了。我保证。什么？你知道你那样说吗？你知道怎么说吗？不。我听你这么说。我不那么说。但我确实，我尽量在排练中多做一些构建，因为我发现我喜欢，
I like people to be open to do. I mean, honestly, I mean from theater, like, table work, just like what, you know, any questions and how does this work? And I think if there's improv that comes out of that that then wants to get worked into the script, I really do like words to be written just because it is like, you know, movies are so, you can really get pulled in different directions and also seduced by how talented everyone is
我喜欢人们愿意去做。我是说，老实说，我是从剧院出来的，比如围读，就是什么，你知道，有什么问题，这怎么运作？如果从中产生了即兴创作，然后想要加入剧本，我确实喜欢把文字写下来，因为电影确实是这样，你真的会被拉向不同的方向，也会被每个人的才华所诱惑，
that you can be like, wait, are we telling the story or am I just letting you get like, and I think so, but I, so I like building it in rehearsal. And then, certainly, I, like, if there are certain actors who are like, I want, can you let me just play a little? I'm more, I would say I'm more open to it than Noah. I think Noah is much more like, say, these lines. A long time ago, a friend of mine worked with Robert Teneiro many, many, many years ago. And this person said that Robert was like, they'd be rehearsing right before they shot it. And he go, no, no, no, no, no, I'm not saying that. And you don't say that either.
以至于你会想：等等，我们在讲故事吗？还是我只是让你……我觉得是这样，但我，所以我喜欢在排练中构建它。然后，当然，如果有些演员说：我想要，你能让我稍微发挥一下吗？我更，我会说我比诺亚更开放。我觉得诺亚更倾向于：说这些台词。很久以前，我的一个朋友和罗伯特·德尼罗合作过很多很多年。这个人说罗伯特当时就像，他们在拍摄前排练，他说：不，不，不，不，我不说那个。你也不要说那个。
Let's just talk how people talk. He goes, because when you say a line and I wait and then I say my line and it doesn't sound real, it sounds like you're waiting for a line. Was it Joe Pesci? Was that Joe Pesci? No. You know, so I found that. I thought that was a Pesci on Hyper-Eye character. Was it Joe Pesci? Yeah, it was Hyper-Eye character.
我们就按人们说话的方式说。他说：因为当你说了这句台词，我等了一下，然后我说我的台词，听起来不真实，听起来像你在等台词。是乔·佩西吗？那是乔·佩西吗？不。你知道，所以我发现了。我以为那是佩西在《好家伙》里的角色。是乔·佩西吗？是的，那是《好家伙》里的角色。
Yeah, it was. Yeah, it was. Now, did you know that Ryan Gosling was as funny as he is or did you just hire him because he's a hot dude that's a perfect Ken. Because he's a funny MFR. Yeah, I knew. I knew. I knew. I did. I really, I felt like I knew. Because we knew we were writing the part for Marco. So we actually, in writing at Cast Ryan, we wrote his name into the script and everything.
是的，是。现在，你知道瑞恩·高斯林有这么幽默吗？还是你只是因为他是个火辣的家伙，是完美的肯才雇他的？因为他是个搞笑的混蛋。是的，我知道。我知道。我知道。我确实。我真的，我觉得我知道。因为我们知道我们是在为玛格特写这个角色。所以我们实际上在写剧本时就选定了瑞恩，我们在剧本里写了他的名字等等。
It was like the thing that I was like, it's Ryan, it's Ryan Gosling, I know. How did you write his name? Was there a match in a Ryan Gosling? No, I said Ken Ryan Gosling. Wow, Ryan Gosling type. Ken Ryan Gosling, and it was everywhere. I was in the weekend, it was in the script.
就像我当时想的那样：是瑞恩，是瑞恩·高斯林，我知道。你怎么写他的名字？剧本里有瑞恩·高斯林吗？不，我写的是“肯 瑞恩·高斯林”。哇，肯 瑞恩·高斯林类型。肯 瑞恩·高斯林，到处都是。在周末，剧本里都有。
The script was like, oh, that's so wonderful that you know Ryan. And I was like, oh, I don't know Ryan. I've never met Ryan. I have no idea. But actually, the thing that made me, I mean, I've always thought of he was like, you know those actors, you can, I mean, they're always my favorite actors, whether they're do comedy or not, you can feel their, they have funny rhythms in them. You can just sort of feel that they know what's funny. And I always felt that about him.
剧本就像：哦，你认识瑞恩真是太好了。我说：哦，我不认识瑞恩。我从来没见过瑞恩。我不知道。但实际上，让我……我是说，我一直认为他就像，你知道那些演员，你可以，我是说，他们一直是我最喜欢的演员，无论他们是否演喜剧，你能感觉到他们的，他们身上有幽默的节奏。你只是能感觉到他们知道什么是好笑的。我一直对他有这种感觉。
And then I'm a big fan of all of his SNLs. I always thought he was great on SNL. And I think he did guy that just got a boat on the penalty. And so good. And I love SNL. I watch every week., I remember that. So good. And I love SNI watch every week. And I always thought he was great. So I had this idea.
然后我是他所有《周六夜现场》（SNL）的忠实粉丝。我一直觉得他在SNL上很棒。我想他演了那个在惩罚中得到船的家伙。太棒了。我爱死SNL了。我每周都看。我记得那个。太棒了。我爱死SNL了，我每周都看。我一直觉得他很棒。所以我有了这个想法。
And then it took him. So he was like, he was not sure. He was like, I don't want to, I'm not going to. I guess. And I was like, I actually, Margo and I just were like, we will do anything and this is, we want you to be in this movie. And um...
然后他花了点时间。所以他当时，他不太确定。他说：我不想，我不打算。我想。我说：我实际上，玛格特和我只是觉得：我们会做任何事，这是，我们想让你出演这部电影。然后……
How was, was he during his first wardrobe fitting? Was he excited or upset about the colors and the materials? Honestly, we had been texting for like a year and talking on the phone and he'd been sending pictures and we'd been going back and forth, but I then I had this like the night before he showed up. I hope this terrible thought. What if he comes and says, I'm not wearing any of that?
他第一次试装时怎么样？他对颜色和材料感到兴奋还是沮丧？老实说，我们已经发了一年的短信，打过电话，他发过照片，我们来来回回，但我当时在，他出现的前一天晚上。我有一个可怕的想法。如果他来了说：我才不穿那些呢？
Even though, and he showed up, and I think the very first outfit he wore was like an all pink sailor outfit. And I was like, wow, he's really doing this. Get out of my closet. Committed. But yeah, he did it. He went for it.
尽管，他出现了，我想他穿的第一套衣服是一套全粉色的水手服。我当时想：哇，他是认真的。从我的衣柜里滚出去。投入。但是的，他做到了。他全力以赴。
So, Greta, what was the first feature film that you directed? And what was that sort of moment where you went, OK, I got to direct this. I got to do this. Well, the first one that I did sort of write and direct on my own was ladybird. And that was. Hold for a while, good. Yeah, no kidding. So that was your first my own was ladybird. And that was. Hold for a pound.
那么，格蕾塔，你执导的第一部剧情片是什么？那个让你觉得“好吧，我必须执导这部电影”的时刻是什么？嗯，我第一个自己写并执导的是《伯德小姐》。那是。等一下，很好。是的，没开玩笑。所以那是你的第一部……我自己的第一部是《伯德小姐》。那是。等一下。
Yeah, no kidding. So that was your first. That was my first. I had co-directed before and I had written before. And then I just, it took me a long time to say, I want to direct. I think because I love movies and there's a kind of fear around it
是的，没开玩笑。所以那是你的第一部。那是我的第一部。我之前联合执导过，也写过剧本。然后我只是，我花了好长时间才说：我想执导。我想是因为我热爱电影，而且周围有一种恐惧，
that you're gonna mess up the floor and all that. So I just... You're gonna ruin the history of film. I know. This is the history of cinema right up until 2017 and that was it. Were there parts of it? Because you're clearly incredible at it.
你会搞砸一切之类的。所以我只是……你会毁了电影史。我知道。这是直到2017年的电影史，就是这样。有其中的部分吗？因为你显然在这方面非常出色。
But you didn't, as you said, you didn't really know if you were going to be. And what part of it do you think you surprise yourself with being not bad at? And what part do you surprise yourself with being a little kind of, well, that's less comfortable for me than I thought it was going to be? Well, I think that the whole thing is uncomfortable. I mean, you know, you've directed,
但你并没有，正如你所说，你并不确定你会成为导演。你觉得哪部分让你惊讶地发现自己做得还不错？哪部分让你惊讶地发现自己有点，嗯，那比我想象的要不舒服？嗯，我觉得整件事都不舒服。我是说，你知道，你执导过，
like, it's the whole thing sort of uncomfortable because it's a lot. It's a lot. Yeah, and also, there's really no way to, I mean, you can go to school for it, but it's also just doing it is the only way you can really get through it and kind of figure out what works and what doesn't work. I always, I think the thing I've always been envious of is like the people who, I don't know any other way to describe it, but that there are some directors,
整件事都有点不舒服，因为这太多了。这太多了。是的，而且，真的没有办法，我是说，你可以去学校学，但只有真正去做，你才能真正熬过去，弄清楚什么有效，什么无效。我一直，我觉得我一直羡慕的是那些人，我不知道怎么形容，但有些导演，
where I feel that they're like native speakers of cinema, that they understand it in just such a deep way. I mean, one of your Stevens-Beeleburgers obviously that. I mean, he almost invented that the modern cinematic language. And I always feel slightly like I'm in translation. Like I feel like, okay, I'm the script, I feel like I can get to a place that feels worthy to shoot. And I feel like I'm good as a director, but I always feel like there's just one layer of translation, which is actually okay, because sometimes there can be things
我觉得他们是电影的母语使用者，他们以如此深刻的方式理解它。我是说，你的史蒂文·斯皮尔伯格显然就是这样。我是说，他几乎发明了现代电影语言。我总觉得我有点像在翻译。就像我觉得，好吧，剧本，我觉得我可以达到一个值得拍摄的程度。我觉得我作为导演还不错，但我总觉得还有一层翻译，这其实没关系，因为有时会有一些
that are quite beautiful that comes out of that. And it's like, I do think, I think something that's always scary about directing, but always exciting about directing is, there's nobody knows, there's no secret, a crib sheet where you can say, well, if you follow these things, it's gonna work. It's a, you know. And as you said earlier, the audience,
非常美的东西从中产生。而且，我确实认为，我觉得导演工作总是令人害怕，但也总是令人兴奋的是，没有人知道，没有秘密的作弊条，你可以说：好吧，如果你遵循这些，它就会成功。这是一个，你知道。正如你刚才所说，观众，
the audience will take whatever you give them. They're wide open and generous, right at that first moment when the screen goes black, right at that first moment, the screen goes black, and then the first image comes up. They'll take whatever you give them, just don't drop them. You know?
观众会接受你给他们的任何东西。他们是完全开放和慷慨的，就在屏幕变黑的那一刻，就在那一刻，屏幕变黑，然后第一张图像出现。他们会接受你给他们的任何东西，只要别让他们失望。你知道吗？
Yes, that's true. That's true. And one of your influences I read, someone I really like, or at least is quote Howard Hawks, where he says, you know, a good movie is just three great scenes and no bad ones.
是的，那是真的。那是真的。我读过你的一位影响者，我非常喜欢的人，或者至少是引用霍华德·霍克斯的话，他说：你知道，一部好电影就是三场伟大的戏，没有烂戏。
Nothing too boring in between. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's just, it doesn't matter what subject matter it's on, what genre it's in. It's just, you just can't have any bad scenes and just have a few that are great. By the way, what if you just your Greta step out of the house, please? Please come out a little bit. I'm not gonna put the dog in your hands. Hands, hands.
中间没有什么太无聊的东西。是啊，是啊，是啊。这只是，无论题材是什么，无论类型是什么。只是，你不能有任何烂戏，只要有几场是伟大的就行。顺便说一句，格蕾塔，你能走出房子吗？请出来一点。我不会把狗放在你手里。手，手。
I know, I know, it's very, it's an intense. He's got a little bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit of a bit from the beginning to Europe for the new one that's coming out. And I was watching, we were watching the third one last night or something. You guys eat in your own sleeping bag when you're doing this. Yeah, okay, sure. We got little treats and I'm wearing my belt card. Anyway, so you know all these space superhero, whatever moves, which I'm a fan of. But it's like you watch these Indiana Jones games. They're just really great, like written and great, you know, amazingly shot,
我知道，我知道，这非常，这很激烈。他有一点点……从头到尾，为了即将上映的新片。我昨晚在看第三部还是什么的。你们在做这个的时候吃自己的睡袋吗？是的，好吧，当然。我们有小零食，我穿着我的腰带。总之，你知道所有这些太空超级英雄，无论什么电影，我是粉丝。但就像你看着这些《夺宝奇兵》游戏。它们真的很棒，写得很好，拍摄得也很棒，
movies that were still action, but they were down here on Earth. And so I think that, if anybody wanted to like take, you know, people by surprise, they do something like that again, instead of up there, they do it down here. Well, I think there's always like, I agree. And I also think like, you know,
依然是动作片，但它们是在地球上。所以我认为，如果有人想让人们感到惊喜，他们会再次做这样的事情，而不是在上面，而是在下面。嗯，我同意。我也认为，你知道，
I mean, one of my favorite directors, movies is the Mad Max Fury Road recently. Yeah, yeah. How he establishes, I mean, and I, there are certainly, you know, great young directors who can do this and I've never done anything like this. But the way he establishes space, and you don't even notice that you understand the relationship between everything into it like it's, but then you realize, oh, he's that's great.
我是说，我最喜欢的导演电影之一是最近的《疯狂的麦克斯：狂暴之路》。是的，是的。他如何建立，我是说，而且，当然有伟大的年轻导演能做到这一点，我从未做过这样的事情。但他建立空间的方式，你甚至没有注意到你理解了其中一切的关系，就像它，但后来你意识到，哦，他，那太棒了。
Like if you know, because I'm not inherently interested in car chases, just as a person. But if you don't establish a geography, there's no suspense. I have no idea. Exactly. But I always felt like in Fury Road, I know where everything is all the time. I understand what is happening. And from the first moment where he runs through that maze of stuff, I'm not confused, even though it's shot very close. And it has a strong stylistic choices. And I think even just tethering things to earth in terms of like geography is thrilling for aliens. And I think to Indiana Jones, you always know where you are.
就像，因为我作为一个普通人，本质上对汽车追逐不感兴趣。但如果你不建立地理位置，就没有悬念。我不知道。没错。但我总觉得在《狂暴之路》中，我一直知道一切在哪里。我理解正在发生什么。从他跑过那个迷宫的第一刻起，我就不困惑，即使它拍得很近。而且它有强烈的风格选择。我认为即使只是在地理上把事情与地球联系起来，对异形来说也是惊心动魄的。我认为对于《夺宝奇兵》，你总是知道你在哪里。
And I think, to me when I talk about people who are like, you know, understand cinema in that way, it's that they just instantly can establish space. When you see that sort of like craftsmanship when it comes to filmmaking, like I was watching somebody was breaking down that scene in the birds, you know, Hitchcock, and seeing the guy outside getting attacked at the gas station
我认为，对我来说，当我谈论那些像，你知道，以那种方式理解电影的人时，就是他们能瞬间建立空间。当你看到那种电影制作的工艺时，就像我在看某人解析《群鸟》里的那场戏，你知道，希区柯克，看到那个家伙在加油站外面被袭击，
and the way he cuts it and he keeps cutting back to inside and everybody, and then you see the gas going down to the thing. Yes. And then the guy stepping on this and everybody's like, don't light the cigarette. And he blows up and then it blows, sorry, spoiler alert. And then he blows, blows up the gas station. And then you end up at the perspective of the birds.
他剪辑的方式，他不断切回室内，每个人，然后你看到汽油流向那个东西。是的。然后那个人踩在上面，每个人都在说：别点烟。然后他爆炸了，然后它爆炸了，抱歉，剧透警告。然后他炸毁了加油站。然后你最终处于鸟的视角。
You are the villain by the end. Looking down at the explode and it's so mesmerizing to see that kind of as the guy broke it down. He was like, don't you get it, you're the villain. And I was like, oh, yeah. So, yeah, it's really impressive. I know, I also think it's impressive when it can be like a Hitchcock thing or like Indiana Jones or whatever,
到最后你就是反派。向下看着爆炸，看到那个人解析它真是太迷人了。他说：你不明白吗，你就是反派。我当时想：哦，是的。所以，是的，这真的很令人印象深刻。我知道，我也认为当它能像希区柯克或《夺宝奇兵》或其他什么东西时，令人印象深刻，
where you're so caught up in the storytelling and it's in service of the storytelling, but not you never say to yourself, well, look at that shot. Right, you're just in it. Yes. Yes. And I think that that's like, I always think of like in,
你完全沉浸在故事讲述中，它为故事讲述服务，但你永远不会对自己说：好吧，看看那个镜头。没错，你就在其中。是的。是的。我认为这就像，我总是想到，
in jobs, the shot where the car comes on the ferry, and then it, it's one shot. It's like a five shot that becomes a three shot, that becomes a two shot, and it's like, they didn't cut the whole time, and you never think about it. You're never like, he's doing a winner. Yeah, no, yeah, right. It's just great.
在《大白鲨》中，汽车上渡轮的镜头，然后它，这是一个镜头。它是一个五人镜头变成了三人镜头，变成了双人镜头，就像，他们全程没有剪辑，你从来没想过。你从来不会想：他做了一个赢家。是的，不，是的，没错。这太棒了。
And I think that kind of thing and that like to Howard Hawks or Preston Sturgers or InSlobuchar, those guys who made those wonderful, like I think we'd call them talkies, but they were also so cinematic. That it's this combination of like the highest respect for words and then also just clean, beautiful storytelling with great ideas
我认为那种事情，那种像霍华德·霍克斯或普雷斯顿·斯特奇斯或恩斯特·刘别谦，那些制作了那些美妙的，我想我们会称之为有声电影，但它们也非常电影化。这是对文字的最高尊重与干净、美丽的叙事以及伟大的想法的结合，
for shots that aren't fussy. And I think that that kind of unfussy filmmaking that's language first, but yet also gorgeous. It's like, I always think of that like a high water mark. Yeah, when it's understated like that, when you don't know, and you can just appreciate it for what it is, but it doesn't stick out. It's like wearing a really great shirt, but with no logo.
对于那些不繁琐的镜头。我认为那种不繁琐的电影制作，语言优先，但又华丽。我总是认为那是一个高水位线。是的，当它如此低调时，当你不知道时，你可以欣赏它的本来面目，但它并不突出。就像穿一件非常棒的衬衫，但没有标志。
Do you know what I mean? Like you don't need to advertise it, it just happens to look good. I think the analogy holds up. Or beautifully cut suit or something. Yeah, that's what I mean. Unless the shirt or the sweatshirt would ever set smart lists on it. But anyway, it's like really so much. It's like a merch store.
你知道我的意思吗？你不需要宣传它，它只是看起来很好。我认为这个类比成立。或者剪裁精美的西装之类的。是的，这就是我的意思。除非衬衫或运动衫上写着“Smartless”。但总之，它真的很……就像一家周边商店。
It's like a merch store. It's like a merch store. Go to the merch store. Hey, Greta, do you know where the word movie comes from? No, I don't. So the original studios were in Brooklyn, right? They weren't in LA, they were in Brooklyn. And the people working on the set who walked around,
就像一家周边商店。就像一家周边商店。去周边商店吧。嘿，格蕾塔，你知道“电影”（movie）这个词的由来吗？不，我不知道。所以最初的制片厂在布鲁克林，对吧？它们不在洛杉矶，它们在布鲁克林。在片场走来走去的工作人员，
they were, what the fuck? What the fuck? They moved, right? They called all the people that moved around the set who walked around, they were, what the fuck? They moved, right? They called all the people that moved around the set, they called them movies. Wait, the people, they called the movies. The people would move around. I see.
他们是，什么鬼？什么鬼？他们移动了，对吧？他们把所有在片场走来走去的人，他们是，什么鬼？他们移动了，对吧？他们把所有在片场走来走去的人，他们称他们为“电影”（movies）。等等，那些人，他们称他们为电影。人们会走来走去。我明白了。
Moving, Brooklyn, I love that. Now there's something to cut. Hey, Alfredo. I got it. When you're in love movies so much, if you couldn't make movies or act in them, what else would you do? Yes. Huh?
移动，布鲁克林，我喜欢这个。现在有东西可以剪了。嘿，阿尔弗雷多。我明白了。当你如此热爱电影时，如果你不能制作电影或在其中表演，你还会做什么？是的。哈？
There's a question. Never had that. Wow. I mean, this is like not a job that's available anymore because the world has changed, but like in the- Luxembourg. I think I've always like- I like-
这是一个问题。从来没想过。哇。我是说，这就像不再是一个可用的工作了，因为世界变了，但就像在……卢森堡。我想我一直喜欢……我喜欢……
I like John- No, no, no. in the- Luxembourg. I think I've always like, I like- Copy. I like John- No, no, no. Like, like old-timey newsrooms, like, if they were like, get the paper out every day. We got a rush this one. What's that deadline? Yeah.
我喜欢约翰……不，不，不。在……卢森堡。我想我一直喜欢，我喜欢……复制。我喜欢约翰……不，不，不。像，像老派的新闻编辑室，如果他们像，每天把报纸发出去。我们得赶这一篇。截止日期是什么？是的。
So you want to be a copy, copy, copy writer? Yeah. Yeah. A big reporter. Like, one of the ladies in all the presidents, men, who was like, you know, but I do like that idea of like, we gotta get it out every day. And like, we're gonna go to press,
所以你想成为一名文案，文案，文案撰稿人？是的。是的。一名大记者。就像《总统班底》里的女士们，她们就像，你知道，但我确实喜欢那种“我们必须每天把它发出去”的想法。而且就像，我们要去印刷，
and then we're gonna get scooped to them, like all of that stuff. I think so, so that kind of like pressure of every single day, there's a deadline. Extra. Yeah. Now, what about when you're, what about what would you, you are making movies,
然后我们要被他们抢先报道，就像所有那些东西。我想是的，所以那种每天都有截止日期的压力。号外。是的。那么，当你，当你正在制作电影时，
and then how do you decompress when you get home? I know you got those two wonderful kids to deal with. But what else, what would you do? What about when they're down? And then mommy needs to take it easy and she needs to refill her bucket. We're turning on TV, we're reading poetry, we're... So I do, I no, and I do watch a lot of movies together. I think like my sort of, that's something I read a lot of books, but I also really, here it comes. Love, love is blind.
然后你回家后如何减压？我知道你有两个可爱的孩子要照顾。但还有什么，你会做什么？当他们睡着后呢？然后妈妈需要放松一下，她需要补充能量。我们打开电视，我们读诗，我们……所以我确实，我没有，我和诺亚确实一起看很多电影。我想就像我的那种，那是，我读很多书，但我确实也，它来了。爱是盲目的。
You love, love is blind. Yeah, you can't stop watching that. You can't stop. I love it so much. Sure. I love people falling in love. Right on television in the dark. In their hearts. It just makes me so happy. Well, it's like a bachelor. It's so real. I've never seen the bachelor, but actually Ryan, Ryan Gosling, when he, when we started talking about Ken, he said that Ken, all the Ken's, I'd never seen him and he was like,
你喜欢《爱情盲选》，是啊，你根本停不下来。你停不下来。我太喜欢了。当然。我喜欢看人们坠入爱河。就在电视上，在黑暗中。在他们心里。这让我感到非常快乐。嗯，就像《单身汉》一样。太真实了。我从没看过《单身汉》，但瑞恩，瑞恩·高斯林，当我们开始谈论肯的时候，他说肯，所有的肯，我从没见过他，他说，
oh, Ken reminds me of the men on the bachelor rep when the woman is in a round. They don't know what to do with themselves and they get my dress down. And they're like, still drinking. I just start drinking. That's what dudes do. And they kind of like are competitive with each other
哦，肯让我想起了《单身汉》里的男人们，当女人在场的时候。他们不知道该怎么办，他们会变得很拘谨。他们还在喝酒。我只是开始喝酒。这就是男人们会做的事。他们有点像是在互相竞争
and it's like if one guy wears glasses and then another guy wears glasses, he's like, no, you took my thing. I'm the guy with glasses. Oh my god the top not. I probably would love the bachelor and the bachelor but I've never seen it but I love love his blind. I mean that's like it's that's that's that's not a very exciting answer. Well the first the first season of love is blind there's one couple that's still together. I know. Not wow. I know. They're in love. Lauren and Cameron. Yeah.
就像如果一个人戴着眼镜，另一个人也戴着眼镜，他会说，不，你抢了我的东西。我才是那个戴眼镜的人。天哪，那个发髻。我可能也会喜欢《单身汉》和《单身女郎》，但我从没看过，但我喜欢《爱情盲选》。我是说，那，那，那，那不是一个很令人兴奋的答案。嗯，第一季《爱情盲选》里有一对情侣现在还在一起。我知道。不是吧。我知道。他们相爱了。劳伦和卡梅伦。是的。
Exactly. Lauren and Cameron, wherever you are, Besselok, huh? Besselok, huh? Besselok. They're doing great. Greta, you're, this has been a very fast now. Oh my gosh. You're a very quick fast.
没错。劳伦和卡梅伦，无论你们在哪里，祝好运，哈？祝好运，哈？祝好运。他们过得很好。格蕾塔，你，这真是太快了。天哪。你真是个快节奏的人。
Yes. This is wonderful. You've got real chat skills, okay? Yeah. The directing and the acting doesn't work out. Maybe radio. Please, please, it's going to work out. Please don't stop making movies and writing and directing and the acting doesn't work out. Maybe radio please please it's gonna work out. Please don't stop making movies and writing and directing and acting all of it.
是的。这太棒了。你真的很有聊天技巧，对吧？是的。如果导演和表演行不通。也许可以去广播电台。拜托，拜托，一定会成功的。请不要停止制作电影、写作、导演，如果表演行不通。也许可以去广播电台，拜托，拜托，一定会成功的。请不要停止制作电影、写作、导演和表演，所有这些。
You're so I also can't wait. You're so great at it. Oh, yes. Oh, thank you. Well, I'm Yeah, and I'm excited to see you in your Tony award winning performance. Go see it. Go see it.
你真是，我也等不及了。你在这方面太棒了。哦，是的。哦，谢谢。嗯，我，是的，我很期待看到你获得托尼奖的表演。去看看吧。去看看吧。
I go and also I've just started because my son's now four months old. I've. Go see it. I go, I am. And also, I've just started because my son's now four months old. I've just started like being able to go out at night. Doing stuff. Yeah. I've got, I've got a date to see parade. So then right off, like it's, I'm getting a minute, but yeah, I can't wait. Well, thanks honey.
我去，而且我刚开始，因为我儿子现在四个月大了。我。去看看吧。我去，我是。而且，我刚开始，因为我儿子现在四个月大了。我刚开始能晚上出门。做些事情。是的。我有个约会去看《游行》。所以，就像，我得找个时间，但是的，我等不及了。嗯，谢谢亲爱的。
It's so nice. Well, you're the greatest. You're super duper talented, very, very kind to do this with us. Thank you very much. Thank you guys. This is it was like being at my own surprise party on the thank you for doing this. Best of luck with Barbie. Cannot wait to see it. Yes, best of luck. Thank you, Greta. You guys are going to like it. I can't wait. I'll be there. We're going to be there opening weekend.
太好了。嗯，你是最棒的。你非常有才华，非常非常感谢你和我们一起做这件事。非常感谢。谢谢你们。这就像是在我自己的惊喜派对上，谢谢你们做这些。祝《芭比》好运。等不及要看了。是的，祝好运。谢谢你，格蕾塔·葛韦格。谢谢格蕾塔。谢谢。谢谢。
Yeah, I'm going as Ken for Halloween. I'm already tapping it. No one else can take it. And he's got the outfit on now for it. Thank you, Greta Gerwig. Thanks Greta. Thank you. Thank you.
再见。再见。她有一部非常令人兴奋的电影要上映了。我只是觉得《芭比》是个庞然大物。我觉得它真的很大。是的，真的很大。它会很火。我是说，想想看，她只是在写作和制作这些令人难以置信的电影，而且
Bye. Bye. She's got a very exciting movie coming out. I just think that Barbie is a monster. I think it's really huge. Yeah, that's really huge. It's gonna be huge. I mean, think about it, she's just writing and making these incredible films and it's
作为一名演员也太令人兴奋了。不，我知道。我只是说像杰森。等等，抱歉，肖恩，你在吃东西吗？抱歉，是的，我感觉好多了。哦，是的，是午餐时间吗？我们快结束了。现在，肖恩，我在节目中看到你，你是肖恩，你在吃东西吗？抱歉，是的，我感觉还好。哦，是的，是午餐时间吗？我们快结束了。现在肖恩，我看到你，你在节目中被杀死了，
so exciting to be an actor too. No, I know. I'm just saying like Jason. Wait, so sorry, Sean, are you eating? Sorry, yeah, I'm feeling so much better. Oh, yeah, is it lunchtime? We're almost done. Now, Sean, I saw you during the show, you were Sean, are you eating? Sorry, yeah, I'm feeling okay. Oh yeah, is it lunchtime? We're almost done. Now Sean, I saw you, you were killed during the show,
你正在喝一大杯可乐。是的。你有一大杯可乐？一大杯可乐。然后是什么，你在嚼什么？芝士脆。还在吃芝士脆。是的。
you were killing a big coke. Yeah. You got a big coke on? Big glass of coke. And then what's, what are you chewing? Cheezards. Still on the cheezards. Yeah.
有趣的零食。这是一个，这是一个，自助餐式的努力吗？是的，有自助餐，而且。是的，有趣的零食。这是一个，这是一个，这是一个自助餐式的努力吗？是的，我厨房里有自助餐，芝士脆。不同口味的芝士脆。我只是顺着排队。我说，斯科蒂，你差不多了，你能把队伍往前挪一下吗？
Fun snack. Is it a, is it a, all you can eat, endeavor we got here? Yeah, there's a buffet and. Yeah, fun snack. Is it a, is it a, is it a, all you can eat endeavor we got here? Yeah, there's a buffet in my kitchen, cheese it. Different flavors of cheeses. I just go down the line. I'm like, Scotty, you almost, can you move the line in the long please?
斯科蒂，斯科蒂，在你自己厨房里从食物中学习？我很高兴，因为我以为那部电影，你知道，是《芭比》，但因为我第一次想到时，我以为是酒吧。不，再见。那是个很好的再见。那是个很好的，你不能用那个。我有一个更好的。我有一个。
Scotty, Scotty, learning up from food in your own kitchen? I'm happy because I thought that the film, you know, it's Barbie, but because when I first thought I thought that it was bar. No, bye. That was a very good bar by me. That was a very good, you can't go on that one. I had a better one. I've got a one.
继续。我太兴奋了，她不负责门。我从来没有被拒绝过。我太兴奋她拍了《芭比》。我太兴奋要去看它了。你知道，我被警告过，因为它是一个如此庞大的特许经营项目，对很多人来说很重要。但看起来她真的做得很对。
Go ahead. I'm so excited that she doesn't work the door. I've never been denied. I was so excited that she did Barbie. I'm so excited to see it. You know, and I was warned because it's such a big huge, you know, franchise and important to a lot of people. But it looks like something she really did right.
我做对了。哦，做对了。是的，你确实做对了。做对了。哦，那会过去的。你觉得那比我的好吗？嗯，关键工作，门开了，我们走吧。再见，高尔。
I right by. Oh, did right by. Yes, you did do right by. Right by. Oh, that will go. Do you think that's better than mine? Well, the key work, the doors open and out we go. Bye, gawl.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
SmartLess 是由罗伯·阿姆杰夫、本内特·巴巴科和迈克尔·格兰特里手工制作的 100% 有机艺术作品。本集录制于 6 月 20 日。我们的下一集将在下周发布，无论你在哪里收听播客，或者你现在就可以在 Amazon Music 上提前收听，或者通过订阅 Apple Podcasts 或 Wondry 应用程序中的 Wondry Plus 提前且无广告地收听。自 2009 年去世以来，世界一直在纠结如何记住迈克尔·杰克逊，是作为流行音乐之王，还是作为一个怪物。我是莱昂·内法克，《Fiasco》的主持人和《Slow Burn》的联合创作者。我是杰·斯穆斯，一位嘻哈记者和文化评论员。
SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael Granteri. This episode was recorded on June 20th. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts, or the Wondri app. Since his death in 2009, the world has struggled with how Michael Jackson should be remembered, as the King of Pop, or as a monster. I'm Leon Nefak, the host of Fiasco and the co-creator of Slow Burn. And I'm Jay Smooth, a hip-hop journalist and cultural commentator.
迈克尔·杰克逊在 1993 年首次被指控猥亵儿童。我们的新播客《三思而后行：迈克尔·杰克逊》讲述了之前和之后发生的故事。在整个播客中，我们探讨了是什么让迈克尔·杰克逊看起来无法被取消。我们深入挖掘了当我们听到在杂货店播放《Billie Jean》时，我们许多人心中复杂的感受。
Michael Jackson was accused of child molestation for the first time in 1993. Our new podcast Think Twice, Michael Jackson, is the story of what came before and what came after. Throughout the podcast, we explore what makes Michael Jackson seemingly uncancellable. And we dig into the complicated feelings so many of us have when we hear Billie Jean at the grocery store.
通过对亲眼目睹故事发展的人们进行的数十次原创采访，《三思而后行》试图调和我们对迈克尔·杰克逊这个人的矛盾情感，以及我们对他艺术的深厚热爱。无论你在哪里获取播客，都可以收听《三思而后行：迈克尔·杰克逊》，或者你可以在 Audible 或 Amazon Music 应用程序上无广告地狂刷整个系列。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
Through dozens of original interviews with people who watched the story unfold firsthand, think twice as an attempt to reconcile our conflicted emotions about Michael Jackson, the man with our deep-seated love of his art. Listen to think emotions about Michael Jackson, the man, with our deep-seated love of his art. Listen to Think Twice, Michael Jackson, wherever you get your podcasts, or you can binge the entire series at free, unaudible, or the Amazon Music App. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。